first one is n minus two times 180 this
equals the sum of the interior angles in
a polygon so all the interior angles
added up I just want to show you quickly
where that comes from so say for example
you have a polygon like this okay you
can divide this into 1 2 3 triangles and
we know the sum of the measures of the
angles in a triangle add up to 180
this particular polygon I drew has 1 2 3
4 5 sides 5 minus 2 is 3 and you can see
there's three triangles there so 3 times
180 equals 540 so that's where this
formula comes into play is you're gonna
have two less triangles okay then the
number of sides or angles that you have
in the polygon so it's always going to
be 2 less now this formula here n minus
2 times 180 divided by n we use this
when you're trying to find the measure
of one interior angle in a regular
polygon
now regular means that all the angles
are the same and all the sides are the
same length so when you find out the
total measure of all the interior angles
and you divide that by how many angles
you have that will give you the measure
of just one of those interior angles ok
this formula 360 divided by n is to find
the measure of one exterior angle that's
saying on the outside of the polygon
again if it's a regular polygon meaning
that all the angles are the same
you take 360 divided by n and then this
last one here is just that the sum of
all the exterior angles in a polygon
they're always going to have to 360 it
doesn't have to be regular they just
they're always going to have to 360 so
for example here if I extend you know
the sides like so these angles that are
formed on the outside of the polygon
here okay those are all going to add up
to 360 like a circle okay so let's get
into some examples I'll show you how
these work excuse me so and this polygon
here you can see we have 1 2 3 4 5
angles or it could count the sides one
two three four five sides so we're going
to do n minus two times 180 equals the
sum of the angles so we have five minus
two
times 180 which is three times 180 which
is 540 okay so if we want to solve for X
this missing angle here we're gonna add
up all these angles okay plus X equals
the total 540 so let's do that so that's
120 plus 80 is 200 plus 100 is 300 Plus
this right angle here that's 90 that's
390 so we have 390 plus x equals 540 so
if we subtract 390 what do we get we get
a hundred and fifty degrees so that's
this angle right here now on this one
here excuse me and this angle on this
polygon here we're trying to solve for
the exterior angle so what we're gonna
do here is we're going to add up all the
angles okay and the exterior angles add
up to 360 so in this one we're just
going to go over here and we're gonna
say alright 90 plus 90 plus 120 that's
90 plus 90 plus 120 plus X this angle
here equals 360 so that's 180 plus 120
is 300
okay so 300 plus x equals 360 and if we
subtract 300 we can see that x equals 60
degrees that's this angle right here
okay now the next one find the measure
of an interior and an exterior angle of
a decagon and what I meant to write here
is a regular decagon so I'll just put
that in there a regular decagon meaning
all the angles and all the sides are the
same so a decagon is like decade right
there's ten years in a decade there's
going to be ten angles in a decagon so
there's a couple different ways to do
this we can either use this formula here
or we could use this formula here I'm
going to use this one here it's going to
be a little bit easier since it's a
regular decagon so I'm just going to
take 360 divided by 10 that equals 36
degrees so each of the exterior angles
of that decagon will be 36 degrees but
one thing that you'll notice is that see
when you extend the side okay like this
the interior angle and the exterior
they're going to be supplementary this
might be a little easier to see here so
when I extended that side exterior angle
and the interior angle see how they form
a line a linear pair they're gonna add
up to 180 so if this is 120 this is 60
if this is 36 right the interior angle
would be 180 minus 36 so that's a
hundred and forty four okay so some days
it's use easier to use this formula than
this formula it's just a little bit
simpler if it's a regular polygon right
okay so then the last one if the sum of
the interior angles of a polygon add to
two thousand three hundred and forty
what type of polygon is it okay so this
one it doesn't specify whether it's
regular or not it just says that that
all the interior angles add up to two
thousand three hundred forty so we're
going to go to this formula here the sum
of the interior angles so it's helpful
to you know memorize these formulas if
you haven't already and let's see if we
can substitute what we have so we have
two thousand three hundred and forty
equals and minus two times 180 okay
I'm gonna divide both sides by 180 okay
this comes out to 13 and then if I add
two to both sides I get 15 equals n so
this is a 15 gone okay so when it starts
to get up in those higher numbers you
can just put 15 - gone 15 sides or 15
angles - God so I hope you've been
enjoying these videos I hope you learned
something sometimes it's just a little
you know piece that's missing that can
make a big difference in boosting your
grade and I hope these videos are
helping you to do that so subscribe to
the channel and take a look at some of
my past videos and I've got some future
videos coming for you so stay tuned and
I'll talk to you soon